thanks
welcome to this informal virtual meeting
of baber district council cabinet i am
councillor john ward leader of baber
district council and i'll be chairing
this meeting today
the decision to hold an informal meeting
has been taken as a result of the
current risks relating to the covert 19
pandemic
as this meeting is now an informal
meeting the cabinet will not be able to
make decisions and therefore there will
be no voting on any items on the agenda
members are asked
to discuss the items on the agenda and
to confirm a steer for each item
which will be recorded and decisions may
then be taken by officers or the leader
under delegation depending on the
decision
may i remind you of some domestic
arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please remember to use the chat function
only to indicate that you wish to speak
and not post comments or questions
please note the messages in the chat
panel can be viewed by people watching
the live broadcast
i would like to remind everyone present
that this informal meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
i'll now ask the governance officer to
carry out the introductions
thank you jen and
present today our counselor mary mclaren
chair of the overu and scrutiny
committee
councillor bryn herron chair of the
joint audits and standards committee
we also have the chief executive present
and the assistant director of law and
governance and the monitor officer
assistant director of corporate
resources and sector section 151 officer
and the assistant director for customers
digital transformation and improvement
we have the corporate manager policy
performance and insight and the acting
corporate manager for finance operations
and me i'm the governor's officer and if
i have admitted anybody and please can
you let it be known now thanks
i think that's probably it thank you
henriette
okay
now
i'll now move on to the agenda
so item one apologies for absence do we
have any
we have no apologies for absence chair
would you like me to do a roll call yes
please
right so members can you please uh
make yourself known to me when i say
your name and counselor clive arsey
ansa arthy are you here
present sorry i i thought i'd unmuted
said present and then muted again but
obviously it got lost thank you
councillor barrett
president
how's the bus bee
yep i'm here
council davis here
council halt yes
councilman vizi
here
uh councillor mccraw president
councillor osborne
present
a ward
here
and council
uh dawson
chair i don't think council dawson has
joined the meeting
right
i will get a colleague to call her and
and see
how we are faring
she was in the um the meeting earlier so
um
it would be good if if we could uh chase
up please thank you very much thanks
okay
moving on to item two to receive
declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interest by members are
there any to declare from anyone
nope
then we'll move on to item three
um
item three uh paper bca2134 the minutes
of the meeting that we held on the 6th
of december
as this is an informal meeting now the
minutes of the meeting held on the 6th
of december will be deferred to the next
cabinet meeting for approval
item 4 accuracy
sorry did did somebody
i don't know sorry i think council
dawson had just joined the meeting yes
sir i can't get that in i might be
intermittent
okay
thanks sean um
can you turn your camera off please
sorry thank you thanks
um right great so that's everyone
present
um so moving on to item four to receive
notification
of petitions in accordance with the
castle's petition scheme
not received item five questions by
councillors
none received
item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or joint audit and
standards committees senator mattis
referred chair
thank you
um right um so moving on item seven
forthcoming decisions list cabinet
members does anyone have any comments
about the forthcoming decisions list
council osborne
yeah thank you um
mr chairman um yeah cab292
which is the rent and service charge
policy um it's got in here that it's to
go to cabinet in february i thought we'd
agree that that would go to cabinet
after the setting of the budget either
march or april
just having a look see um
where we've got i'm looking for that on
my list
what page is it
on um it doesn't give page numbers on
here not on the one that i've got so i
can't help that i'm afraid
i don't think we need to discuss it
today necessarily but i think it's a
question mark over when it actually goes
to be discussed and the other one is the
um
cnl-115 that's the housing revenue
account business plan i would hate to
step on councillor barrett's toes but i
think you'll find that this isn't the
cabinet member for housing but the
cabinet member for finance
does that need some ending
for the business plan
um the hra business plan
yeah no that would be under uh your
portfolio castle
sure really
yeah
yeah
uh but we'll get that confirmed uh
offline okay
the officer thank you and uh there's
only one from me which i think we need
to just clarify as well and that cab 330
um
it references the mid suffix expenditure
program
um
uh i don't know if there is a baby one
or with that's deliberate or whether
there isn't a baby one uh to be
looked at
in march
but um we'll need to get that clarified
as well
okay
um yeah henriette you've got your hand
up yeah yes sorry chair chair for me um
for cab 202 we are currently just
checking with the assistant director for
housing uh where that needs to be on the
forthcome decisions list and of course
we'll make and we'll check who is
cabinet member the correct cabinet
member for the fourth coin decisions
list and update accordingly
okay thank you
um and can you also check on um uh
3 30 as to whether there will be a baba
sil report as well yes of course i've
made a note on all these and i will make
sure that we can check that and we get
the corrected
thank you very much
right um unless there's no uh
any further comments on the decisions
list if not we'll move on then
um to item eight
which is paper bca2135
the outcomes framework so i'll now
invite the cabinet member for customers
digital transformation and improvements
to introduce this report council mccraw
thank you very much chair
i'm going to just introducing the report
as relatively informally as i can
because you have the papers in front of
you so
good afternoon to members happy new year
and uh to anybody who might be watching
uh on the internet
uh the outcomes framework that we have
before us oh i should add that we do
have the presence of the assistant
director sarah wilcock and dr jane
kennedy who's being one of the lead
workers on this particular project so on
any technical matters they may be better
to have address have questions addressed
to them
so this report identifies the need for
the outcomes framework um
there's a basic principle we've been
working on over the last few years in
developing our corporate plan
our sixth strategic priorities we've
moved on to our service plans and the
personal plans the
policies and and the actions that will
be taken
this stage is to ensure that that
corporate delivery plan is delivering
the right activities for our residents
and communities
now you may remember that cabinet
members
contributed to the development of the
outcomes at an away day in october and
an updated framework in december was
presented and we're being asked to agree
that today or at least to provide a
steer for its agreement
and it's a new approach it's slightly
different focus the focus shifts away
from measurement and reporting
in the old ways
away from highlighting activities
outputs and performance indicators to
emphasizing the outcomes that is what is
actually being done as opposed to what
measures people can draw different
conclusions from measures
and we can then demonstrate the impact
of the strategies policies and plans
now the framework operates in a tier
system tier one is the vision of the
council that's followed by 18 strategic
outcome statements three for each
strategic priority and they form tier
two
the short term and flexible range of
tier three is the intermediate outcomes
and that's going to form the core of the
overall outcomes that will form the next
stage tier four
the idea is to help us make sure we
spend our money on the agreed outcomes
for our residents now we already looked
at these over some time
we're seeking to drive the strategic
change and improvement and providing
what we've described in the corporate
plans and from the start of the golden
thread strategy and business planning
arrangements
it's a new performance management
approach and the direction of travel for
reporting embedding a culture of
performance challenge and improvement
now here we're asked to agree three
recommendations or rather to provide a
steer for three recommendations
we have to already agree the first three
tiers those we've been looking at in the
last few months
of the baber outcomes framework as what
that being the new strategic approach to
measuring performance for the council
tier four
will be developed with slt senior
leadership team working with the
corporate managers in each of the uh six
strategic
priorities
relating to their particular specific
measures outputs and key performance
indicators
which will follow in tandem with the
2022 to 2023 service planning cycle
that will feed into our future quarterly
reports on the outcomes framework and
the corporate delivery plan
delegating any minor changes as we have
done in the past this has been done in
terms of minor changes to wording to the
assistant director for the customer
digital transformation and improvement
uh portfolio in consultation with the
relevant portfolio holder
and this will be uh paralleled at
mid-suffolk i should add that tier four
is not something that will just be
sitting around waiting it's going to be
starting work next month and the final
plans are expected in early may
i'm happy to take any basic questions
please remember
tiers one to three
are relatively high level documents and
they can seem very obscure and they can
seem somewhat um aspirational
in this instance we are setting those
aspirations but tier four is where we're
eventually going to see the proof of the
pudding because that will be the
outcomes and that's why we have a
framework for outcomes
thank you over to you members
yep thank you councilman crore um i'll
go through uh members individually to
see if anyone has any questions
counselor arthi any questions from you
no thank you very much
councillor barrett
any questions
uh nothing for me thank you
council busby
i've got a few things in in debate i
guess there's just one point it's not a
question it's just a
consistency
on
the housing
outcome
on two of the three tiers we refer to
residents
but on tier two
our strategic outcomes we then change
that to local people
i have a say in the future of housing
it's only a small thing but just
consistency again terminology and that
can be dealt with by the assistant
director under the third recommendation
in terms of if you say consistency of
wording
yep exactly yeah
councillor davis
nothing from me
counselor dawson no thank you
counselor hulk no
counselor marvissi
uh
councillor busby has addressed the issue
that i queried
okay thank you
um and counselor osborne no question
from me mr chairman
do any other
members of the council present
have any questions
that they'd like to ask on this report
please raise your hand if if that's the
case
okay
i'll now move into the discussion
stage of this
um
any uh cabinet member that wishes to um
make any comments in the discussion
would you please raise your hand
did
councillor busby did you say you wanted
to
say a few things under this yeah council
buzzfeed
yeah um i'm assuming that housing is not
just council housing it's housing of all
types
i guess that should have been a question
but i'm assuming that it's of all types
what worries me is when i read through
all of the various tiers the objectives
etc the outcomes
i think we're going to have a problem
with our joint local plan
because i don't think the two are in
line in sync
and
bearing in mind that the joint local
plan is perhaps
the most important plan that we produce
shouldn't it tie in with what we've got
in here
in
in what way do you do you think there's
a disconnect between the two
well uh
quote
in the outcomes its residents have a say
all residents have a say in the future
of housing
housing is sustainable with reducing
carbon emissions that the future proved
to meet residents needs
communities are attractive successful
and connected places for people who live
and work
community have the capacity and are
supported and empowered with the
infrastructure to maximize opportunities
and thrive
we enjoy valuing our
value
enhance and protect our environment
and we should improve the link between
the corporate plan strategic priorities
service plans and individual plans so
that everyone understands how they
contribute to achieving the joint vision
i just think that
our joint local plan seems out of date
in comparison to what we're suggesting
here
i'm not convinced that uh local people
do have a particular say in the future
of housing
or that the
infrastructure
we're operating offering through the
joint local plan is to maximize
opportunities and thrive
um
well certainly uh residents um and uh
other interested parties um have had
ample opportunity in the various
consultation phases and also
um during the examination of the uh
joint local plan to to have significant
input into it so um
i think that um
well i think if you if yes they might
have an opportunity to
and it's maybe
semantics but having the opportunity to
have a say and having their views taken
on board
at different things i think
if you spoke to the residents of sprout
and pinewood
cop dock
bentley bergot cable i'm not convinced
that they would think that their views
had been taken on board
just to mention half a dozen
can i discuss that
in response
yes please do but i do have some
thoughts on the subject i quite take
councillor busby's report uh a point
it's a good one effectively i mean when
we deal with policy and when we talk
about planning we're very much bound by
the fact of the national planning policy
framework and overall central government
policy now our joint local plan is
obliged to conform to that
i don't see any disparity if i look at
uh
page 18 of the report and the um
outcomes shown there it i think that's
tier two the strategic outcomes in the
light green
on the right-hand side
as all our residents live in affordable
and high quality homes that enable them
to build settle safe and healthy lives
so that's the fundamental overriding
point and you have the three
pieces underneath that
and some of those for the first part is
i believe our joint local plan does
address
if not all of those in every single
action that we'd like
the broad principle is that we are
looking for all those things and
i have to say recalling the jlp that our
policies do conform to those strategic
objectives i can't see any disparity
there
the ability
to um fulfill that is
circumscribed by central government
policy and the joint local plan is
required to do that so we know that we
have
limitations placed upon us but in this
instance we don't have the limitations
this is what we think
as opposed to what um
outside central government necessarily
thinks
so yeah i can see the difficulties
how much say residents should have in
the future of housing and you're correct
it does deal with all forms of housing
both for the private market um
affordable housing and and of course our
own housing i hope that answers the
question but i think it's a it's an
ongoing issue that we're always going to
have with planning policy
yeah okay
one of the items under tier 3 on housing
new homes are in high quality
sustainable environments served by jobs
community facilities
spaces
and effective transport links
and here we are at the aspirational
level
not entirely under our control
but this is these are uh this is a tier
that we are going to be
measured on on the the delivery of these
things
and as i said i don't think the jlp
supports that well
i think it's
just
that's a matter of opinion obviously but
i'm just trying to explain why it is the
case that it is um we're dealing with
the reality here but this instance is
less to do with what um
this is a measurement we're setting for
ourselves um
these these are aspirational what would
be interesting and i think this is where
members um across the council as well as
the cabinet will be able to feed in is
what specifically within the tier four
outcomes that we actually ask for and i
think that's where we can shape uh the
and address the point that you're making
counselor arthi
yeah um
part partly this is stuff that you've
said but i think it is consistent with
the ambitions of the joint local plan um
as you've as you've said that involved
significant engagement um before the
statutory consultation period on the
submission document
and i have spoken to councillor busby
about this before particularly with
regard to cable there will be more
opportunities to discuss infrastructure
requirements with communities um
wherever that development is going to
occur um of course we've still got to
get the final
adopted plan um but i've undertaken with
um capal that we will certainly go out
there and discuss all of the various
infrastructure wishes if you like
and
you know so that's something that's
going to happen at some time in the
future so i think it's a little bit
unfair to say that hasn't happened yet
um these things happen in stages um and
when this when this development is
approved if it is
we will be going into
a round of discussions with local
communities regarding their
infrastructure needs and how to deliver
thank you council arthi
councillor busby um
are you uh
satisfied to to a certain extent to
today i'm i think
well i think we
uh
the challenges with regard to the joint
local plan um but as it's been pointed
out uh the aspirations here
in in this document are clear and the
joint local plan
um
is doing its level best to uh to meet
those aspirations um in order to build
the right communities and provide the
right homes uh and and the supporting
infrastructure so um
but it is it is an ongoing challenge and
um one which um
is is still uh still being worked on
yeah i think my issue is
primarily
with the jlp not necessarily with this
outcome yeah report
so
yeah
i should look forward to see how we can
amend the jlp to reflect
what we've proposed in here
okay thank you does anyone else uh have
any uh points they wish to uh say about
this report here um and under this
discussion
section
if not um i'll i'll just say that uh
it is
a lot of work's been put into this um
it is a completely new way of measuring
our performance
um and and
and
measuring it on on outcomes is is going
to make it far more relevant and far
more easily understood to our residents
so
um but it has required a completely
different mindset and and the rethink of
how we do this um hence the detail that
we've got in the report and the further
detail as we get down to level four that
will come
and i'm very sure that councilman mccraw
will be able to drive that through
so that we do have um
a performance measuring capability that
that is um
very much geared to ensuring we are
delivering uh against our corporate plan
um
can i ask council award if it's possible
because i know we can't have a vote on
this if we were to have a vote i'd be
proposing this paper but could i ask for
and we were expecting a steer from
captain what i'm coming to yeah thank
you i apologize that's all i have i
don't know how we deal with how do you
steer we can't vote
no well what i'm going to uh to ask is
unless anyone has any um
uh significant disagreement um can i
assume that we're all in favor of this
report um and its contents councilor
busby
well yes i am but just again one small
minor thing on on the
tier
three
the under housing
in the uh
in the boxes on the right one two three
four five six on the seventh box down
which is the first in the residents have
a say in the future of housing the
sentence is not complete
it just says residents are included and
actively participating
participate participate in how there
it doesn't say how their what
okay um
right well if councilman mccraw can can
make a note of that um and then the page
please yeah what page number we on
uh oh hang on we're on page
27
thank you
well the first thing is of course that's
so that's tier three uh intermediate
outcomes
wording can be changed that's not a
difficulty that is part of the ongoing
process under recommendation three
tier four though i think is the more
significant one
um
sarah you've got your hand up afternoon
council award just to um
interrupt i think it might just be a
visual display um point with that
particular
comment that councillor has raised
because i can read that it it states
residents are included and actively
participate in how their areas are
evolving and changing so it might just
be a display issue
okay
thanks thanks sarah
right okay then um
given what what's been said and nobody
has any violent disagreements um based
on the discussion that's taken place i
am minded to accept uh the three
recommendations at paragraph three um
and uh and we'll take that forward then
um and any further minor changes that
anyone identifies obviously um
uh will be delegated to the the
assistant director um to to make those
minor changes in in consultation with
council mccraw
okay everyone um moving on then the next
item is item nine paper bca2136 fees and
charges for
2022-23
now invite the cabinet member for
finance to to introduce the report
councillor barrett please
hi um right so you've got the report in
front of you basically this is uh
a report coming to council with our
revised um charges
for the up and coming year for the
budget year 2022-23
um it's pretty uh self-explanatory uh
there's a whole schedule of charges
which are there you've got appendix a b
d e
um
can
consider a number of those charges are
set centrally so we are just adopting
the charges set for planning and
building control etc from central
government and those are there other
charges where we have um our own control
of obviously being included and
highlighted in yellow on the various
reports where the charges have gone up
um the
point i do need to make clear
there's an admission which has now been
in your table papers
of brown bin charges
has gone up by 2 pounds or 3.6 percent
and that has been put in the agenda
supplement which you will see
which is uh additional to the
original paperwork
so really all i would say is that uh
this will obviously be going
forward to um
uh this will go forward to full council
for the part of the fudge so eventually
so um really just
a
that's that's my presentation i'm not
quite sure what i've got to do now john
with his
non-non-non-thing non-thing whatever
okay um i'll uh thank you uh council
barrett um we'll have some questions now
from cabinet members firstly counselor
arthi do you have any questions
i do yeah um i've got a couple actually
the first one is around um is it page 48
and it's statutory charges and we've got
i think land charges and um electoral
roll
um charges
which are still to be confirmed and i'm
not quite sure why that is the statutory
charge is presumably fixed so what is it
that we're waiting for to confirm those
we're probably waiting for central
government to confirm their charges
okay
um and the second question um is about
the um the new fees for pavement
licenses pleasure boats and street
trading
where these apparently are
fees that we've introduced um afresh or
or that we didn't have before and i'm
just wondering what we did before
because presumably we had people
operating on pavements um and street
trading so i'm not quite sure what
happened before if there's a new
i i have no idea whether we charged or
not if we didn't they got away with it
um
and presumably this has
come about as a result of us not having
a policy so what page was that on clive
those are on page 37
um that there's a new charges um
the pavement licenses certainly was
something that was introduced um uh
during the covert lockdowns or or coming
out of lockdown um
to enable cafes and and uh bars
restaurants etc to um
uh
to to be able to
have um tables on on pavements outside
i think it must be a new thing because
see mid suffolk i don't even have the
pleasure boat licensing i don't think
they've got it
um so i'm not quite sure
but clearly that's a a a
charges that again
i'm not are they new i don't think
they're new are they
well it says in the paper that they're
new yeah you fees added as follows new
it says new fees it doesn't say new
charges does it
or new is it a new charge or is it just
a new fee
i i i in all fairness i'm not i'm not
aware of that i'd have to
find out where that is a totally new one
uh being brought in
have we got anybody on the meeting that
can help us with that
um
no
no we don't have it i think i'm just
having a look look down there's no one
here
oh catherine's catherine's here
rebecca or rebecca catherine let's say
off afternoon cancellers um i don't know
the exact answer i just uh asked rebecca
if she knew
um i think she just replied to said it's
um
that it's new in the schedule but not
sure if it's entirely new so we can we
can double check that and let you know
but catherine those payment licenses
were introduced um during the covered
lockdowns weren't yeah yes yes
well i'm not even sure about that
because there were people operating on
the pavements before covid yeah
i thought they were suspended during
covert lockdown
uh no that that 80 pound was definitely
something that we um
introduced uh we mustn't get confused
with the uh basic there was a um
relaxation of the pavements so
businesses could extend their offer
in terms of coffee and tables to the
pavements without a license
and that was extended during covid for a
number of people
but that wasn't that wasn't uh us
charging for that
um that was just an extension of
um
i think it came about when
businesses were able to serve copy
outside
and they were able to use the the
pavement for do it whereas before they
hadn't been able to
okay could i just say that i'm looking
at page 50
um which is the schedule
and there's nothing in there for a
previous charge
so it does look as though they are newly
introduced
well that that
that's new to me clive because it wasn't
on my
it didn't come up as a new charge when i
was having briefings so i'll have to
i'll have we'll have to come back to you
on that one
i think they were there in i mean if you
look at page 10 discretionary charges
there's a whole host of uh in theory new
charges including street trading well
we'd certainly charge the street trading
before i just don't think the 21 22
charges have been shown
sorry dave what page was that
well it's paid 10 of the report
chair
yes
oh sorry um
i i think it's you could say i want to
say something first i don't know whether
he's beating me to say that the
licensing was introduced last year but
then
please go ahead give a sec
yeah okay yeah
yeah go ahead sorry
thank you
my documents here to find try and find
an answer i i was going to save save
councillors trying to find answers and
certainly trying to stop them from
guessing which i think we're in danger
of doing so as councillor barrett has
already said we'll find the answer out
and we'll come back to members and we
can email all around all members to
confirm
okay
thank you arthur
liz
casey
liz do you have a question
i'll come back um castle mccraw your
hands up as well
i was going to agree with something
councillor barrett said about the
pavement licenses and the relaxations
that took place during the lockdown
periods to allow
businesses to continue but i noticed
these are discretionary charges under
caravan licensing and other licensing
presumably and again i might be doing
what uh chief executive has suggested we
shouldn't do which is guess
but it would seem that we weren't
exercising that discretion prior to this
year
um
that would certainly be the um
uh the implication the discretionary
charges are are those that we we can um
uh
put on on services uh at any time uh to
cover the costs of those uh providing
the service so
i'd also add i don't know how many um
people would be subject to such uh
discretionary charges that's another
matter entirely but
i don't think it very high pleasure boat
licenses in mid-suffolk for example
i don't think they even have the
schedule of charges in there i'm pretty
certain
but we have places where pleasure boats
might be used and they may not
yeah there's no pleasure in midsole
we have the rivers
um council halt
yeah i was just going to say if you look
on our website at the moment you can
actually apply for a payment license
which is 80 pounds yeah exactly yeah
okay
thank you councillor
osborne
thank you mr chairman uh yeah page 52
charge for the collection of up to five
items
um considering the current problems that
we have with domestic fly tipping
it may be at some point within a few
months that we decide
to go with an alternative system and
pricing structure so my question is if
that is the case
will we be able to do still go down in
that direction if we approve the current
charge outlined in the report before us
today
um that probably needs to go to
the cabinet member for environment
rather than me
because that's a policy thing rather
than the charges isn't it
it is yeah
um
so uh council dawson i i don't know if
you wanted to uh quickly answer that
question
say it again
this this uh council osborne has has
asked whether um
if we were to make a any changes to the
bulky waste
uh collection
tariff at some point in the future um
whether that can still be done
irrespective of whether we approve this
um
slight increase in the charge today or
not
well mine's saying is it can't be till
next may but on the other hand we've got
a proposal we're going to put forward
um
which
i've mentioned to her earlier that we're
going to discuss which will deal with
this problem outside of this
and i think it will be a lot more cost
effective for the council
so the problem will be dealt with
um so it doesn't really matter whether
we can change it or not because we've
got another solution to the issue which
will be better for baber
yeah
thank you for that
sorry mr chairman if i can come in on
that that doesn't actually answer my
question
i'm asking if we approve it today
can we change it before we get to the
next financial year
i was under the impression that we could
but now it would appear going by the
portfolio holder for the environment
that we cannot
um
all we've got here is is a current um
uh charge for a a single charge for
bulky item collection um whether we uh
keep the charge at the 20
the current 21 22 rate or whether we
increase it with an inflationary
increase of 22 23
it's just for that single
charge that that decision would have no
impact on
any alternative tariff that we may or
may not wish to introduce at a later
date we're just looking specifically at
an inflationary increase on on the
current um
single rate charge for
bulky waste collection
and it's never been changed during the
year previously so there's no reason why
it would be going forward
i don't know if um
if cass is uh here
whether she might
john we set the rates um for the year
and this has just got a usual as you
quite rightly say uh it's got usual
inflationary increase and that's it
yeah we're not absolutely we're we're
not at this stage we're just looking at
the the current charges and that we have
um
in place and and looking at um uh
the the influential increase on those
current charges we're not making any
assumptions or any decisions about an
alternative charging schedule at this
stage
so i mean it strikes me that if if we
decide to introduce a different charging
schedule that can come forward as a
recommendation i would have thought from
the um environment portfolio to be voted
on at cabinet and then introduced as a
charge into the into our charge schedule
so i don't think we need to over
complicate this particularly
no no i i think we're
probably um
making it far too difficult for
ourselves so arthur have you got a
comment you wish to make on on this
i just was just going to agree with that
latter comment you of course you can set
fees and charges you can change fees and
charges that's that's up to you at a
later point in time in the year if you
choose to do so in terms of a different
policy approach that's perfectly
possible
i was just going back a step if i may
because i've had some further
confirmation in relation to both the
pavement licenses and the pleasure boats
so the reason for the pleasure boats
being introduced is because we've had an
application for one for the first time
ever or first time in many years rather
and so that has brought it to our
attention and therefore looking to make
sure that we can deal with that and
recruit the costs of administering that
license and similarly with the pavement
licenses it wouldn't have been in last
year's schedule because it didn't exist
at that point in time it did come in
mid-year it was one of the decisions
that i made as part of the delegated
authority at the time in relation to
covert changes
and exactly as council barrett referred
to earlier
in terms of provide making provision for
recovery so that businesses could uh
could have payment licenses um and trade
accordingly that's why you now see it in
this year's schedule as a result
and if i could just add um
catherine and emily would need to advise
if we can if we wanted to change it
mid-year
with the via the cabinet route
sorry say that again castle dawson
um catherine or emily would need to
confirm if we can do anything mid-year i
see yeah and then so and then we can um
via a cabinet decision
but that that's um outside of the scope
of this particular report we've got here
today but yeah thank you for that
are there any other questions um on this
report
um if not i have one quick one
um and that is on page 95 the um
uh the comparison in terms of the the
service
total charge totals um
uh comparing this year with uh next year
um
presumably given the
um
table paper that we've got for the the
inflationary rise two pounds on the
bulky way sorry on the garden waste
collection
then the uh the corresponding item
on page 95 would would have to be
updated as well because there'll be a
slight increase in the the total income
for that service
um
assuming that what we have on page 95 is
excluding that two two pound rise that's
correct you'd have to increase that and
that would actually be a slight positive
again towards the budget contribution
of the extra two pounds per per pin
yeah
so that's that would be uh obviously
need to be added in and that will come
forward when we obviously do the uh
budget uh budget preparation work
okay uh thank you for that um now um
before i go to questions from other
members present a note that uh catherine
steele uh you've got your hand up
did you have something you wish to
yes
thank you chair and i just wanted to
clarify on that last point in terms of
the two pounds um that was the the
reason why this came to light that it
hadn't been included in the schedule
because we have actually included that
two pound increase in the budget
proposals for next year but it was
omitted from the schedule so we so it is
already included in the figures that are
in that appendix b in your report today
but yeah it was just missing from the
schedule so apologies for that
okay thanks thanks for that catherine
that's that's great
um
okay uh again before i go to uh other
members for their questions and i know
to council buzzfeed you put your hand up
again do you have another question or is
this something for the discussion stage
yes
i don't know which one it is
it's just a small thing
why are we
charging pence in these things litter
bin 37 pounds 13 p
dog bins 43 pounds 49
i would think dave that is a historical
thing of percentage increases as opposed
to monetary increases which
would be the reason for that well it
just seems crazy i mean hazardous waste
48 pounds 16
55 pounds 49 asbestos yes but then and
then you see if we round this up round
it down round everything up then we're
accused of rounding everything up
good or rounding it down or rounding
down what would you prefer or shall we
just be exact and have a percentage
increase
i think we should just round up
we need to counselor buzznee says we
should round everything up
um
i think we do need to
keep to percentage increases because
then we
we can demonstrate um uh the rationale
behind an increase
as as a percentage to take into account
the corresponding percentage increases
in the cpi
so um i think we need to stick with
percentage increases
all of those were the same as last year
so they've not had an increase
they would have done at some point
we don't increase everything
everything
everything doesn't just get increased
because it can be increased we'll we'll
um we'll move on now um councilor hinton
uh do you have a question
yeah just a quick one really it
refers back as well to what you've just
been saying about percentage increases
um two pounds on the br blue bit oh
sorry on the brown bins it's 3.6 percent
according to councillor barrett
um is this going to be for a guaranteed
number of collections because we've
already lost four uh two collections
this last month and there are officials
that were lost and yet people were
paying extra for them they were
reimbursed on their bill for the re bins
that weren't collected they were yeah
including thought including the re
either are people going to be reimbursed
for the bins that weren't collected
during december then because there'd be
no brand collections during december
when they when the renewal came through
the
when they were not collected there was a
credit for the non-collection on the
bill
but that was the previous financial year
we're now talking about a different
financial year well i assume that if it
goes through again and we have no they
will do exactly the same as they did the
last time
so that two pounds could be
nullified then
well it would be but then it wouldn't
have had any cost because we wouldn't
have collected the bin would we
we um i i think the the principal
council hinton is that we um reimburse
when there are uh significant
miscollections of of um brown bins um
but um
we have to at this point
um put in the slight increase in in the
service
charge because the the cost to ourselves
is increasing in terms of um
uh
the the the collection cost for for the
brown bins uh it is only a minor
increase two pounds is is uh very small
um
and uh i think as as we note every year
the um uh uptake of the brown bin
service increases year on year um we
have more and more subscribers um each
year it is a very popular um service and
and those that subscribe to it do
uh do regard it as uh excellent value
for money uh which indeed it is um uh at
only
one pound ten uh a week whatever um it
is uh very good for what um
our residents get for it it's a lot
cheaper than going to the waste tip
it is
it comes into your door just like
just like um deliver
yeah okay right
you don't get a reimbursement
if the waste tip is closed whereas you
do if your bin is not collected
well you've still got the money you've
going there haven't you you that petrol
cost of getting there and then having a
closed thing you've still encouraged
um so if there's no further questions um
i will open this item up for discussion
uh cabinet members does any cabinet
member wish to
say anything else regarding the fees and
charges paper
if so please raise your hands
i think we've probably covered pretty
much everything in in the the question
section but um
council arthi
um yeah just to let you know that whilst
the rest of you were talking um i sought
an answer via the council's website to
the street trading and pavement licenses
and i found one um so if you're
interested uh mid suffolk has not
adopted street trading so it has no
policy and there are no restrictions
baber has adopted street trading in the
past
and there are a list of restrictions so
it tells you where you can and where you
can't trade
and what you have to to do and what
you're not allowed to do
but we haven't charged for licenses in
the past so this is indeed a new charge
so i don't think it's necessary for
anybody to go away and find the answer
for me it was actually on baber's
website yes and uh i think the chief
executive state that
um when you were looking at that
information clive
no i think actually he was referring to
pavements rather than street trading
can you tell me two different licenses
can you tell me the difference
um well yes um because if you want a
pavement license to um
to operate outside your premises on the
pavement it's going to cost you 80
pounds if you want a street trading
license it might cost you 2 450 pounds
so that's like a proper vendors like
burger van type operation is it
i don't know all the details and to be
honest with you i found it it's a it's a
it's it's it's a difference it's like
having a serving of coffee outside your
business isn't it and then having a
full-fledged
completely different thing yeah so to be
fair i was i was just i mean i asked you
the question
um so
um but i found the answer elsewhere
thanks
i'm so pleased you did the the thing
with the um the pavement licenses and i
will come back to uh what i said earlier
is is that um prior to
the
uh to cover there weren't there wasn't
any uh facility to allow restaurants and
other venues to to set up
tables and chairs outside
and this was something that was
introduced uh to help them
uh and i think it was actually about 18
months ago it was a summer
july or august 2020 now
um to to help them uh with their
business recovery
and we introduced a flat fee of of 80
pounds for them to to be able to do that
and i seem to remember at the time
we
also allowed people to
uh set up tables and chairs um prior to
actually getting the license so we
didn't want the paperwork to hold up um
anything they wanted to do to um to help
their businesses so that they could they
could set up tables and chairs and apply
for the licenses retrospectively which i
um i believe a number of businesses did
so um anyway that's um that's a bit of
history from from my uh recollection on
on that
council macro
a minor point on the subject of street
traders licenses at one point in years
gone by i recall that we had no such
facility and that it was possible for a
burger van
or a kebab van to set up within a lay-by
and we had no control over them
whatsoever and yet they were creating a
considerable amount of of waste in the
in the area which we had to do some work
about clearing up so there was a cost
involved we had no means of licensing
them properly and we had no means of
recovering our costs so this is entirely
proper
okay
so are there any other
points that any cabinet member wishes to
make on this
and
if not um
again um
based on the discussion we've just had
i am minded to accept the
recommendations in this report regarding
the fees and charges so that we can
include the new schedule in next month's
budget
so thank you for that members
i will now move on to the final item
item 10 paper bca2137
environmental social and governance
considerations for the council's
treasury management investments
now now invite the cabinet member for
finance to introduce the report
councillor but barrett please
yeah hi um right this is uh this came up
um as a result of a question at overview
and scrutiny
um where the um
position of the council's investments
was uh discussed whether they are to be
taken away from
carbon
generators or
non-green or clean
investments um
and uh
that was disgusted overview and scrutiny
and if i'm correct and i seem to
remember because i sat on that the
general feeling was that yes the um
ideal situation would be that the
council moves away from what i would
suppose you could say dirty investments
and move to clean green
um but it was considered at the time
that it should be done in a way which
doesn't um
have a detrimental effect on the
investments of the council and uh it
should be done in a or a reasonable and
um
sort of a sustainable and fiduciary
responsible way
so
that was where we are and i think that's
basically the recommendation that is uh
before you're at 3.1
thank you councillor barrett
right um
questions from uh cabinet members
councillor arthi do you have any
questions
no thank you chairman
councillor busby
no thanks
councillor davis
council dawson any questions no thank
you
councillor halt
no thank you
councilman vici
any questions liz
councillor mccraw
nothing too bad i would support this
kasser osborne
no questions mr chairman i think it's a
very good recommendation and fully
supported it
um
any other members uh president do you
have any questions
if so please raise your hand
council mclaren
okay
also
before mary before um
liz you just popped your hand up
yes just to say i have no questions to
ask
because you were good around us all and
i missed it
sorry sorry man
go ahead
thank you
chair can we just clarify for the record
um with uh councillor barrett it was
joint audit and scrutiny rather than
overview on scrutiny
yes sorry
you are correct mary yes sorry about
that
yes no it was it was it was joint sorry
i i i got me committees muddled up it's
actually joint audit and standards that
that came to me yeah yeah sorry thank
you which is the appropriate committee
for that actually thank you thank you
thank you thank you councilman
castle
yes thank you chair i did put my hand up
because i was going to correct um
simon councillor barrett on his mistake
as chair of the committee um
i was a bit offended that he was getting
confused but um some gen just some
general sort of flesh on the bones chair
i think um
order standards
the vote was eight nil including um
councillor barrett it was a very strong
vote
and i think um since that meeting in may
i think i feel even stronger about it
than before
we did make the issue that um we don't
want to lose any money and that as chair
i was very strong on that i wouldn't
accept any
vote that left us in financial trouble
but i think since then the way the world
is going
um
we have some
investments that are slightly
underperforming one especially and i
think the fact they are invested where
they are
could be one of the reasons for that
now i know that not all the money is
invested in um
in dirty field as simon puts it but the
fact that it is there i think does make
a difference i think in future um
people will shy away where it's got this
taint to it so i do think we need to be
sharp on our feet
um and look ahead i think um our public
won't forgive us if we don't um grab
this chance while we may something that
is not doing well now if we switch to
something that is quite green and sexy
and 21st century and futuristic
we may stand a better chance of gaining
the loss on a new fund than we do on the
existing one and i think that's the way
the committee felt and um
well i think this um should get a clean
bill of health and maybe be added to but
um
we can't afford to miss this chance
because um
our public will not think one of us
if we skate around it and
don't grant the metal when we can so
thank you for your support and i look
forward to positive result and great to
attend the cabinet meeting thank you
very much
thank you councillor haran it's good to
see you here
i mean i'd just like to point out that i
very rarely forget councillor howard um
he's a
omnipresent um in
my mind but i i must admit i do audit
and standards and ons um they tend to be
a big blur to me so uh i do apologize uh
counselor all right apology accepted i'm
simon happy new year
okay um so we've had questions um uh
we'll move into discussion phase does
any cabinet member wish to make any
comments um about this
if so please raise your hands
counselor arthi
yeah i just wanted to really i think
agree with councillor barrett um
there's a an issue here about how one
makes the judgment
on
what
what companies what types of of business
might have an impact and whether we
should be investing or not
and i'm thinking about people like shell
and bp
um because it's quite likely that
they're actually
investing um
huge amounts
in clean energy um they may well be
based historically on fossil fuels
but because of the the the size of that
background if you like they're better
placed to be able to invest these large
amounts it's in their interest to do so
so that they continue as energy
companies whereas previously they've
been fuel companies
and i think it would be completely wrong
if we actually said that people
shouldn't be invested we shouldn't be
investing in companies like that um
because they historically have been i
think simon called them dirty fuel
producers or something um so i'm wholly
supportive of this i mean it's it's
something that we should um constantly
monitor um but we shouldn't have any
sort of list drawn up by any particular
person to say where we should and
shouldn't invest because we think
they're clean or dirty
yeah i i quite agree with that counselor
arthur we're not in the business of
demonizing certain businesses certain
companies just because um
certain uh pressure groups um have got
it in their minds that um
these these are companies that uh
um must be called out um that as you say
they're increasingly becoming energy
companies and indeed they are big
they're rich they're the only ones who
are really going to be able to provide
the investment in in clean fuels going
forward so um and and their shareholders
will expect that because they've got
those companies have got to survive
they've got to keep providing dividends
to their shareholders so it's in their
interests to to adapt and i'm sure they
will and to encourage them to do so i
mean you've only got to look at the
corporate advertising of companies like
bp and shell that are
putting out that their case for as you
say they're turning from a carbon-based
um energy supplier to a to a an energy
supplier of different types
and clean and uh
that's where we are so it seems that
really as a for us to be it would be
irresponsible to take investments out
and then put them into other industries
at a cost
this is the whole purpose of of this
um paper and and to look at esg
considerations
is is to ensure that um
we're doing the right thing yes but it's
not to uh to grandstand and make
political statements about um businesses
we we do or do not like it it has a far
more
responsible purpose i will also like to
to say that um we do tend to focus on
the environmental aspect of this um
when we're looking at these businesses
and we keep talking about um uh green
energy particularly um the social and
governance considerations must also be
taken into account as well um they they
tend to be lost um uh and swamped by the
environmental considerations but um
uh having said that uh
i think again um
based on the discussion we've had today
the questions we've had today um and i
know the discussions we've had um in the
past about uh about this that um
uh
the steer i've got is that the
recommendation at 3.1
is is uh what the the cabinet uh wishes
to uh to accept and therefore i'm i'm
minded to uh to go with that um unless
anyone now violently disagrees with me
um which case i'll accept that
recommendation on behalf of the cabinet
and therefore that brings us to the
close of today's informal cabinet
meeting um
uh
first of uh this this format um it's
been
forced on us by circumstances it has
felt a bit um different from
not just meeting face to face but also
from when we've had formal meetings um
uh online during curved lockdown
so um
hopefully we'll be back to normal and be
back to uh meeting together in endeavor
house next month um
uh where we'll be discussing and
debating at that point debating and
voting on on the budget papers
so uh until then uh i'd just like to say
that the next meeting is scheduled for
monday 7th of february 2 p.m um and
as i just
indicated uh fully expect that to be an
endeavor house in in the council chamber
but uh thank you everyone for attending
today
you